sí la crisis de los combustibles
continúa en Francia y eso Pese que el
gobierno anunciado Que las próximas
horas va a comenzar la requisición de
una parte de los trabajadores de los
depósitos de combustible de la petrolera
estadounidense eso móvil que tiene en
normandía como ayer lo advirtió la
primera ministra Elizabeth recordemos
que los trabajadores de la petrolera de
Estados Unidos y también de la francesa
total llevan más de 10 días en huelga
pidiendo mejoras salariales lo que
mantiene un tercio del país sin gasolina
hoy el ministro portavoz del gobierno
liberal dijo que la situación debiera ir
normalizándose en las próximas horas sin
embargo reconoció también que se está
volviendo insoportable para una parte
importante de los franceses así que por
lo mismo el gobierno no descarta
requisicional a los trabajadores de otro
depósito de combustible esta vez en el
norte del país cerca de dunkerque que es
otra de las regiones afectadas por este
movimiento de huelga en total de siete
refinerías que hay en Francia 6 se
encuentran en huelga y además los
trabajadores del sindicato cgt de 5
reactores nucleares se han puesto
también en huelga en Solidaridad con los
trabajadores de las refinerías por su
parte los directivos de la empresa
francesa total han aceptado reunirse con
Los líderes sindicales de la empresa
total del sindicato cgt hasta ahora se
habían negado si esto no levantaban el
movimiento quizás podría ser un inicio
de solución mientras sigue las colas en
las gasolineras con prioridad para los
médicos los policías y las personas
minusválidas el presidente Manuel macron
será entrevistado además esta noche en
la televisión pública quizás se refiere
a esta crisis